Rana McDaniel is the chair of the
Republican National Committee and she is
trying to beat off a challenge from
pillow Mike pillow is challenging Ronald
McDaniel uh for the RNC chairship
chairpersonship and McDaniel appeared on
Fox news with Stuart Varney and Varney
to his credit asked a perfectly fine
question which is you know it didn't go
that well for republicans in the
November 8th 2022 midterms does Trump
bear some responsibility for that and
Ronald McDaniel did not like that
question would you publicly say that
Donald Trump Bears any responsibility
for the sum of the losses in the midterm
elections would you say that publicly I
don't like this I don't like these
parceling out because he supported Ted
Budd who won and he supported JD Vance
who won I think there's a lot of things
that's why I've put together we're going
to go back to that that's an interesting
statement Your Action Report we've got
to look at Dobbs but here's the one
thing that I think people should be
talking about the amount of ticket
splitting the amount of Republicans that
went out and voted for a republican at
the top of the ticket look at Arizona
the top vote getter is a republican look
at a Georgia we had eight of nine
Statewide races won by Republicans but
why are Republicans going and voting for
one Republican and not the other because
they put out uniquely disastrous
candidates disastrous candidates people
like Carey Lake people like Herschel
Walker Doug mastriana one of the most
disastrous possible people that they
that's why the ticket splitting is
happening they have to work hard to
bring those Independence
question the answer is Trump isn't it
I'm saying I'm not into the
no I think we've got to do she's like
we've got to figure out why that
happened well here's one reason why it
might have happened oh yeah but I don't
want to be doing the blame game you said
you want the answer but you don't want
that answer I guess analysis I think
it's too quick and I think you can't
parcel out will this endorsement help
this one and this it's the whole message
it's what did each candidate do what was
their turnout but most importantly how
do we get independence to support
Republicans and yeah I mean listen I say
study it study it but when you ask
yourself well why did Brian Kemp win so
easily in Georgia and Herschel Walker
lost Herschel Walker was a uniquely
disastrous candidate and by the way he
almost won like it it fortunately it
didn't happen but he almost won uh the
other I mean listen I don't know to what
degree Ronald McDaniel is telling us
what she really believes or she has to
put on a face right but
McCain voters
are not necessarily the types of people
who are going to get behind Kerry Lake
because Trump said vote lake so I I
don't know how you disassociate the Maga
candidate even if you don't want to
point to Trump specifically from some of
these decisions that took place and they
talk about Let's do an analysis do an
analysis they'll never accept the
analysis of what it points to is Trump
just really messed things up or at least
publicly they they won't
um we're going to continue having this
conversation because it is a very
interesting one but I question
to what degree they honestly want the
actual answer it seems increasingly the
Republican voters have figured out the
answer because we looked at that poll in
the last segment or the previous segment
um which found that two-thirds of
Republicans don't want Trump to be the
nominee those are pretty significant
numbers before you go if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more please
make sure to subscribe to my YouTube
channel you can click the Subscribe
button below or above or wherever it is
on your screen and if you want to
support my work even more strongly the
best way is to get a membership at
joinpakman.com And subscribe to the
podcast for the David packman show there
you can check out interviews longer
clips and much more it's on all the big
podcasting platforms just search for the
David packman show and all the links are
also Down Below in the video description